this first german chancellor angela
merkel has warned the covet situation in
the country
is very serious as she announces a new
round of harsh
nationwide restrictions till mid-april
that includes a ban
on gatherings and the closure of shops
it's effectively shutting down public
activity over easter
even we are in a situation which is very
serious
the number of cases is rising
exponentially and intensive care beds
are filling up again
it comes after a german research
institute confirmed the country had
entered a third
wave of infections now that's new in
last week saw the
highest number of daily coronavirus
cases in two months
and a massive corruption scandal two
other face masks has now reached the top
with the health minister himself facing
questions wrapping it all up our europe
correspondent with the latest this
morning
the federal government here in berlin
has extended covert 19 restrictions
across the whole country
but that is amid a mask crisis
which has ensnared a new face the german
health minister
a report over the weekend in the online
version of news magazine der spagel
claimed that yenspahn authorized the
purchase of more than
half a million masks from a company
called birder
birder's berlin boss mr spahn's husband
himself
daniel funke the company insists mr
funke had
nothing to do with this transaction that
no commission was paid
and denies any wrongdoing whatsoever
media the board of huber bird media
offered the health ministry to assist
with mask procurement
when the german government was in urgent
need for
this the ceo approached the minister
directly
but that means that the border
representative in berlin
mr funke was not informed about the mask
business
neither by his company nor his husband
who had been the direct
contact person that contradicts common
sense
i can only repeat that according to
birder mr spahn's husband was not
informed or involved in the transaction
at any time
an earlier version of the article had
claimed that birder was owned by the
health minister's husband
that was later corrected to reflect mr
funke's role
as an employee but that hasn't stopped
lawmakers
from seeking clarifications from the
health minister
this salami tactic with the bit by bit
information from the ministry of health
about the procurement of masks
undermines the trust in the institutions
of our democracy
it has to stop we now need an
independent transparency officer to shed
light on what is going on
the health minister himself is biased
mr spahn's allies have dismissed the
spiegel article as
thin soup but opposition parties are
circling
and can smell blood the buddha
publishing house owns papers like bunte
buddha also deals in masks half a
million went to spawn's health ministry
buddha's berlin representative is
spawn's husband
both like to attend buddha parties
because somehow the villa has to be paid
what does one actually have to do in the
miracle cabinet to be dismissed
of course procurement had to be done
quickly during the crisis
but the awarding of 4.6 billion euros
without a call for tenders
is under considerable suspicion in view
of the corruption scandals
two ruling coalition politicians have
already fallen due to personal business
dealings and masks for profit scandals
but what started out as a probe into
pandemic profiteerings
now morphed into a wider investigation
into
what money german politicians have been
making aside from their ministerial
salaries
the scandal has caused real damage to
the ruling conservative
union's reputation they suffered huge
historic losses in recent local
elections with the green
party taking up the slack in one of
those areas and
nationally when it comes to polling they
are emerging as a real potential
challenger in this september's bundestag
elections
in what's been called the super election
year here in germany
there couldn't be a worse time to have
the whiff of corruption
surrounding you peter oliver rt berlin
i'll discuss the situation in germany in
a bit more depth with a member of the
ruling party embroiled in the mars
scandal he told me the country's more
divided than ever
and to make things worse people are fed
up with contradictory lockdown rules
introduced by the government
germany has never been as polarized as
this in its uh
post-war history we have a gap between
rich and
rich and poor country and city young and
old left and right nationalists and
patriots
people are fed up with the lockdowns
i've just had reports from from a
different source from russia that pretty
much life is back to normal
it's it's tough it's one of the toughest
countries here in germany some other
european countries too but
germany politicians are basically
toppling over each other to
raise the bar to make it even more
difficult for people
plus the vaccination counts germans if
they're used to one thing are used to an
orderly state orderly administrative
procedures and we don't see any of this
and we see contradictory
administrative orders we see
contradictory
and failing policies so germans are fed
up but
they don't draw the requisite and
appropriate conclusions in the right
numbers that this government has failed
you